hello everyone today I want to see and  experience the world of Final Fantasy 15  we are excited to show you the  first-ever demo of Xbox one I will be  played by map if will be played when map  take away map Thank You Tabata Sonia  before we move on to the gameplay I  would like to explain a little bit about  the demo we're about to show what we're  about to see is the trial of Titan  noctus and his allies are being tested  by the gigantic Titan but while they're  fighting the opposing army joins the  fray setting up a chaotic three-way  battle we're excited to show how fast  and fluid the battle system is in Final  Fantasy 15 which has never been achieved  in any of our previous titles now let's  move on to the demo  I'm gonna teach anymore of this crap  did you apologize  nice guy  getting by  Jeff  games  thank you mapped that was great  Final Fantasy 15 will be deleted on  September 30th thank you for watching  and have a great day